[Music]
I'm gonna work hey everybody its Charlie
this is gonna be my Deadpool to
post-credits scene explainer video
hopefully you've had a chance to see the
movie if not careful for spoilers there
are multiple post credits in the film
make sure you stay through the entire
film technically there are five but
really it's like one big post-credit
scene with five different parts so if
you hear people talking about multiple
post-credit scenes they're really
talking about this one big scene with a
bunch of different parts to it if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Deadpool videos
there's gonna be a whole bunch of stuff
posting this weekend and giveaway stuff
that I'll explain at the end of the
video but cable has a time travel device
everybody knows about that from the
comics time travel big source of comedy
it gets burnt out when cable uses it for
the last time to save Deadpool in the
first post-credit scene you see
negasonic fixing it then giving it to
Deadpool and telling him saying you
better not misuse this or cable will
kill you so of course Deadpool does the
exact opposite of that and starts using
it going back to quote-unquote fix the
timeline so these other four scenes are
essentially different scenes with him
jumping around to moments some of them
getting more meta than others the first
one is of him going back to save Vanessa
who gets killed earlier in the movie he
kills the person that tries to kill her
with a piece of cutlery so it's just
this really funny moment where he saves
his girlfriend there are a lot of people
arguing whether or not this is canonical
if it's in the movie then it's canonical
even if it's a post-credits scene it's
meant to be a funny moment but yes you
see it on screen
it's canon to the timeline so I'll
explain that when it gets a little more
complicated with these other scenes too
so the next scene is of him jumping back
in time to right before Peter dies
during the film and convinces him to go
back to his normal life he saves Peter
but does not save any of the other
members of the team that have died thus
far I don't think we need to talk about
every single character that dies during
the film during this video just ones
that are relevant to the post-credits
scene so if Peter comes back during the
x-force movie it's gonna be some funny
explainer but I think this is them
saying that he's not going to be a
member of
the x-force team that Drew Goddard is
doing for the x-force movie but the next
scene is where we get really meta here
so we'll talk about timelines and what's
Cannon and what's not Cannon so he jumps
back to the events of Wolverine Origins
when the Deadpool version of himself
during that movie the mouth less weird
head Deadpool is fighting a younger
version of Wolverine Hugh Jackman shoots
him then says de frame just cleaning up
the timelines and you see Wolverine from
behind a little bit so it's is weird
seeing Hugh Jackman in this scene but
it's not Hugh Jackman himself starring
it and it's just them reworking some of
the footage from the Wolverine Origins
movie so it's mostly new Ryan Reynolds
inserted into what's going on during
this
[Music]
but at the end of the movie it sort of
explains how Hugh Jackman isn't actually
in the movie they're just using his
likeness he gets a special thanks for
allowing his likeness to be used during
the film so this way they don't
completely break the Logan timeline
because he's supposed to have died in
the future so this is jumping way back
into the past
considering that Logan is kind of
ambiguous about the timeline and what
happened and what hasn't happened but
because this is happening within the
Deadpool movie you can treat the events
of Wolverine Origins like their cannon
although really it's just one in a
couple really big fourth-wall break
post-credit scenes so that's why you're
probably hearing people say the Deadpool
2 has some of the best post-credit
scenes of any kind of Marvel movie
including infinity war although there'll
be a lot of internet arguments about who
has the actual best post-credits scene
the final post-credit scene in possibly
the most meta because it jumps into
another universe is the Deadpool
character traveling back in time to 2011
into a room where the actual Ryan
Reynolds is reading a script for Green
Lantern getting ready to sign the
contract the younger version of Ryan
Reynolds says to himself you're in the
big leagues now kid the camera cuts to
the script it says Green Lantern on the
top of it you hear a gunshot from the
distance and then blood splash on the
front page so it's basically Deadpool
killing Ryan Reynolds before he can sign
the contract
for Green Lantern preventing Green
Lantern from happening quote-unquote
fixing the timeline so it's almost like
he's fixing the end of Wolverine Origins
you know just so many things we could
say about that but also I think probably
the funnier one is in preventing himself
from starring in Green Lantern so if
you've heard people talk about bringing
back the most notable joke from the
first Deadpool movie the Green Lantern
joke but doing it better this is what
they're talking about doing it to the
nth degree and putting Deadpool in the
DC Universe or in real world technically
depending on how you want to think about
it it's just doing Deadpool fourth wall
breaks the best way possible so while I
will say that infinity war probably has
one of the coolest post-credit scenes
this year one of the coolest Marvel MCU
post-credits scenes ever I'll go so far
as to say that the Deadpool post-credit
scenes are just as good
but obviously for a very different
reason for being so funny going for a
very different kind of reaction than the
Marvel MCU post-credit scenes which
although they have funny moments in them
are treated more seriously but talking a
little bit more about how the movie
treats the timeline in the way they
treat the x-force characters the reason
why I think they use them the way they
did is because Drew Goddard hasn't
started writing the x-force movie yet
they said that you won't even start
doing that till later this year but they
didn't want him to be shackled to what
they were doing with this movie so while
Deadpool is gonna be in x-force
and it'll be a funny movie it probably
won't have the exact same tone as
Deadpool Ryan Reynolds did say it's a
pretty safe bet that x-force will wind
up being r-rated but a lot of that
doesn't get determined till really late
in the Edit after they finished shooting
the movie and doing special effects and
the MPAA starts evaluating it but if you
think the Deadpool is just this parade
of pop culture jokes fourth wall breaks
and a lot of r-rated action imagine that
x-force dials back a little bit on the
wall-to-wall pop-culture jokes and dials
up a little bit on the infinity war
scale of big action set pieces because
it will be a big team up movie but the
whole idea of the ending of Deadpool is
as the cable uses up his last remaining
charge to save Deadpool so they're
basically on the same team now although
they're not like best buds it's not like
cables gonna go around hugging everybody
all the time now Ryan Reynolds has
talked a lot about Deadpool 3 whether or
not they're actually gonna do it but the
writers did say that they have ideas so
it sounds like they're planning on
making a Deadpool 3 and it'll fit
somewhere between x-force sequels
they were talking more specifically
about dealing with cables origin story
in the techno-organic virus and what
that means for the Deadpool universe
because that gets into larger strife
Mutant Liberation Front apocalypse stuff
and they haven't really dealt with that
in the Deadpool universe yet that's been
mostly main x-men timeline but per that
x-men scene in the x-mansion deadpool is
within the timeline of the current team
of x-men you can make guesses on when
that's happening in the timeline
relative to Dark Phoenix in x-men
apocalypse you know the first class
movies but it sounds like they're gonna
dedicate Deadpool 3 or one of those
future sequels to cables backstories
specifically and get more in
to that most of the high-level people
involved with the franchise be it
producers writers or the actors think
that Disney is just gonna let them do
their own thing so I would be willing to
bet that not a lot of their original
plans for Deadpool will get changed they
just allow them a little bit more
freedom with the Marvel MCU characters
in potential future sequels but that's
still on the drawing table right now
we'll talk about that when we learn more
about the Disney Fox deal there were so
many crazy Easter eggs and cameos and
deleted scenes that we need to talk
about I'll do videos for all that stuff
across the weekend my next video will
probably be my spoiler review so be sure
to go see the movie this weekend and
then just let me know in the comments
which other Deadpool videos you want me
to do next
so because the movie is still relatively
early out if you want to talk about
anything spoilery please use spoiler
tags in the comments but like I said
there is a giveaway going on right now
for the black panther of blu-ray
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video announce a winner when I post my
Deadpool spoiler review tomorrow so
while you wait for everything click here
for my non-spoilery review and click
here for that infinity war eternal scene
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you